there's a brand new report that is
coming out which involves the fdic the
federal reserve and the occ they
recently held a crypto sprint these
three organizations came together and
they said let us look at this industry
what should we be worried about what do
we like about it what rules apply and
what new rules could we potentially want
these u.s agencies are weary that
there's a crackdown coming and what they
are trying to figure out is how do they
coordinate their policies when the banks
are permitted to engage in digital
currency activities it's one thing when
new entrants uh people who are
challengers outside of the legacy system
they're building new technology they're
building new companies they're building
new teams and they're trying to figure
it out but if all of a sudden you begin
to let the legacy incumbent players the
big banks the big financial
organizations all start to play in the
industry to hold these assets to
participate in these financial services
then of course the government agencies
that oversee them in some form or
fashion want to know what is going on
and they want to set clear guidance and
rules for how they should enter into the
space
michael sue i believe is how you say it
said that the federal agencies are close
to releasing a joint statement
describing the results of their crypto
sprint he said that the forthcoming
releases will clarify that safety and
soundness is paramount we will proceed
carefully and cautiously and will hold
banks to the same he's the acting chief
of the office of the comptroller of the
currency we then have a second quote
from this says the agencies are
approaching crypto activities very
carefully with a high degree of caution
i'm not personally surprised that we
have the fdic the federal reserve and
the occ saying listen this is all new we
need to figure out how it works we need
to approach it with caution we need to
make sure that we keep safety and
soundness is paramount that all is
almost of course they were going to do
that the question becomes though when
they actually issue a joint statement
will they take a position on certain
aspects of the industry will they say we
believe this
is legal or this is within the
regulatory bounds but these other
activities are not or will they simply
provide guidance that tells banks to be
cautious to make sure that they are
keeping safety and soundness we don't
know yet but this report is coming and
so to see them saying hey we are going
to have a crypto sprint to see these
three organizations working together
tells you that they are taking it
seriously what ends up happening is
there's a very unique innovator's
dilemma if you are a legacy bank and
today your entire pride of your business
your brand your relationship with your
customers is predicated on the fact that
we are conservative we do not take risk
you can trust us right we are the
trusted third-party intermediary the
second that you start to go into some of
these new technologies some portion of
your customer base is going to say wait
a minute i thought you were a
conservative why are you playing in this
new stuff and so ultimately the belief
of the challengers the new industry the
people and bitcoin and cryptocurrencies
they believe that many of the
technologies they're building will end
up competing with and potentially
becoming superior to the legacy system
or to the legacy players and so if you
are a legacy player you have to make a
decision are we going to ignore it are
we only going to focus on our core
business are we going to continue to let
the cash cow run or are we willing to
potentially disrupt ourselves by going
and using some of the new technology now
of course there are some people who will
navigate this correctly i always joke
that goldman sachs has been around for
more than a hundred years they literally
have navigated everything from the
creation of the internet telephones
mobile phones etc they have been able to
navigate many many technology
innovations and evolutions so people
like that who continue to reinvent
themselves who continue to incorporate
new technologies and become successful
they are likely to actually do pretty
well here it's in the dna of what they
do is to use new technology but there's
plenty of old school firms whether it's
because the leadership team is out of
touch with technology or their dna is
just the last mover those are the people
who are most susceptible because it's
one thing when the internet comes around
or when mobile phones come around those
are technologies that could help you do
your job but they're not directly a
replacement for your services they may
help you do a better job but they don't
necessarily replace what you do this is
different if all of a sudden you're
talking about hey we're in the lending
business but there's a decentralized
lending opportunity that ends up being a
zero-sum game to some degree so what i
think we're going to watch happen is
that there's going to be a contrarian
idea today eventually become a consensus
idea which is these banks are going to
continue to push further and further and
further into the industry and they're
going to embrace this new technology
because they're going to have to now
many of them are waiting because they
need this guidance they need to have
their compliance officers their lawyers
and their regulators give them the green
light if the occ the federal reserve and
the fdic come out and say listen we give
you the green light within these
parameters within this box go do these
activities as long as you do these
activities you're good
expect every single bank or financial
institution to immediately run to that
area so in some way when the regulators
and the lawyers and the compliance
departments and fdic
federal reserve occ etc come out with
this guidance they essentially are going
to be putting a much bigger
tailwind behind a certain part of the
industry so we'll see how that happens
are we shocked at all that one these
organizations are coming together and
working together to do this and two what
do we think is going to be in the report
do we think it's going to be kind of an
attack on the industry or do we think
that it's actually going to serve as a
net positive and they'll draw those
parameters and banks will now start to
participate in a more meaningful way i
think it could be both okay what i mean
by that is uh by attacking certain parts
of the crypto ecosystem and industry uh
it could be a net positive right i think
that if you go after the stuff that is
bad things that are obvious scams things
where people are losing money things
that are not regulated things that do
not make sense uh those
are technically an attack on crypto as
an ecosystem you can you can debate
whether it's a good part of crypto or
should be included in the general
thought process uh but it's an attack
but i think that also brings a net
positive when it comes to the overall
industry because when you look at things
like bitcoin uh it like it it stands for
everything that's good about the
industry in my mind right and there's
nothing that they're gonna be able to do
that says hey uh we're gonna shut this
industry down bitcoin's gonna go to zero
and we don't want any of it right like
it's just not possible we've seen other
countries attempt to do things like this
where they're not allowing ownership
they're banning mining they're doing all
these things and bitcoin's gotten to a
point now where i believe the network is
way too strong the ownership base is way
too strong politicians own it right like
like we've gotten past the point of what
they can do from a shutdown perspective
and i think what they're going to do now
is try to put some controls in place
that make these markets a little safer
and i don't think bitcoin is the worry
when it comes to that right i think it's
some of these other altcoins some of
these other projects some of these other
scams quite frankly uh that are going to
be hurt by these these rules and
regulations whenever they do come out or
these procedures and i think it's gonna
be a net positive for people who own
bitcoin specifically the three agencies
working on this the federal reserve the
fdic and the occ it's great that they're
all coming together to work and look at
one specific industry they've been
working on this crypto sprint and i put
that in quotes because they've been
sprinting for months now um they started
this i believe in may so look i think
michael said it and he's been hinting at
the fact that this the results of this
report will not be industry friendly i
think they're going to try to crack down
on the industry within stable content
cryptocurrencies and how banks operate
within that realm uh but look we can
only see and we kind of just have to sit
and wait until the results are published
for everyone to see
but yeah look i don't think it's going
to be industry friendly um i think there
will be some parts that help and i think
a little bit of regulation is good for
the industry because there's a lot
there's a lot of skeptics around the
industry about what people can and can't
do and it's people call it the wild west
of crypto right like there's literally
just there's not a lot of rules in place
right now and i think over the next few
years we're going to see a lot of
different rules be established whether
they're good or bad for the industry